hello everyone and welcome to round 5
well rather Game five of the 1971
candidates match between Bobby Fischer
and the mark Temenos now as in Game
three oh I already did a video on game
number four some year ago but I will not
be doing a remake of that video as that
video is pretty much all about the end
game and I really covered the end game
extensively in that video so if you
haven't seen game number 4 already I
will put a link to it it will be the
first thing you will see in the
description below so feel free to pause
the video now watch Game four comeback
and then continue watching game number
five so you would be you know up-to-date
with your vast knowledge so for those of
you who just did that congratulations
you are an excellent subscriber and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show we are continuing with Game five
so by now you know that Fischer is in
the lead four to zero in this tournament
and this is simply unacceptable for for
the Soviet Grandmaster and of course for
all the Soviets so something must be
done again taimanov has the white pieces
and again you will see in this game
he doesn't mind already two games have
been played in the Kings Indian defense
Bobby Fischer won both of them in this
game time honorable yet again employ the
Kings Indian defense well he will he
will not mind if a Fisher employs it but
Fisher I will decide not to play it now
but as you'll see all that let's use
this for once again to get in in the
mood for this game now let's check it
out
so like we've said that amount of opens
with d4 Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to c3
and d5 now so here
Fisher and that doesn't go for better to
g7 rather he was for d5 and opted for
the groom's of the defense we have
Bishop to g5 the Stockholm variation of
the groom felt now comes 94 Bishop to h4
tal says that some newer tournaments
that have been played have found some
very nice continuations for black in
regard to this Bishop trade for a move
but Temenos still says that this is this
is better for white so okay we have
Knight captures on c3 be captures on c3
and now D captures on c4 we now enter
the same variation
Bobby Fischer played with the black
pieces against Enrique making in the
Buenos Aires tournament of 1970 we
already discussed that so the amount of
likes the idea making one for e3 Bishop
to e6
Bobby continues in the same fashion we
have worked to b1 and b6 and this is the
exact same position Fischer had in 1970
against and DK making in the Buenos
Aires tournament and here making went
for knife to f3 and after Knight to f3
Bishop to g7 Knight d2 first one for
castles and black had a very nice
position of course you can always grab
the the extra pawn here but here after
this is b6 move time on of one for
Bishop to e2 it seems like a really
timid move like nothing's going on here
but it's actually a really poisonous
move so by by moving this Bishop from f1
to e2 really gives the black a lot of
problems for example if Fischer
continues in the same fashion that he
went against making for example Bishop
to g7 now you get Bishop to f3 attacking
the rook on a8 and after c6 you get
Knight to e2 this Knight is now coming
to a4 and from there we'll attack the
bishop on e6 this will be very nice for
white
another thing after this b6 move and
Bishop to e2 you cannot go with c5
because now you get Bishop to f3 and you
have to give up the exchange if you try
to defend this position with Bishop to
d5 white immediately wins with Quint way
for Czech nice to see 6 and now Queen
captures on c6 a temporary Queen
sacrifice button captures Bishop
captures so the King has nowhere to go
we have to block with the Queen and now
characters captures and you see that
white is up a whole piece a White has an
extra night so it seems like really you
know no big deal night a3 Bishop to e2
but actually a very poisonous move so
the amount of Cape came prepared as he
didn't know about the making versus
Fischer game so ok Fischer finds that
Bishop to h6
he doesn't mind this variation Bishop to
f3 that we just discussed the word the
night will come to e2 and then the
bishop will be covering the f4 square so
for a moment
guarding the f4 Square but at some point
Fischer will have to lose a temple to
bring it back to the g7 square we have
to f3 c6 and then out comes Knight to e5
and here if ever goes for Bishop to g7
he you could also play something like b5
to try and keep an eye on all of the
pawns and but then Bishop to f3 again
attacking here Queen b6 and our d5 could
be very unpleasant for black so if
you're not prepared for this actually
time Anna was as he did come prepared
Fisher does not go for this so after
Knight to e5 we have Bishop to g7
fetcher brings it back and now f4 and
here if you this is a very powerful
Knight if you ever capture it then you
simply give white too strong a center
white can freely cast I'll bring a rook
over to the semi-open F file it will be
a very nice position to play for white
so after f4 I would have Bush up to d5
Fischer finds a nice way to keep
everything on the board and guard all
the pawns we have castles Knight to d7
and now Knight captures on c4 we have
castles and here a for a very nice move
and now it's very interesting if you
play something like rook to see it you
face this nice 2d to move this is the
threat y time on have played a four you
don't want this pawn on a two to be a
target for the bishop and here after
night 2 D to see 44 would be very very
you know nice threats for white as this
Bishop doesn't really have all that many
squares to go to here you would have to
make a square for an f7 but then see for
Bishop f7 9 f3 this Knight is not coming
to the 5 again a very nice position for
white so after a for not allowing it to
stay a target the Fischer finds c5 we
have Knight to e5 and now Fischer has to
capture with Knight captures on e5 if he
goes for something like Knight to f6
then again c4 is coming but up to b7 and
d5 you don't want to allow this
beautiful central structure so 95 we
have Knight captures D captures on e5
and now while you might want to play
something like Bishop to b4 offer a
trade of Queens also this comes with an
attack on the rook Fischer doesn't go
for this as there's still this problem
of this Bishop attacking d7 point so
instead again we have one of those
situations where it is
actually okay to play f6 Fisher plays f6
and here we have rook to be to a
beautiful move by time on of not
allowing Bishop to b4 to come with tempo
but also preparing rook to d1 this would
win a piece because the bishop will be
attacked twice your only way of
defending it is e six but then c-4
simply attacks the pinned piece and it's
all over Bobby goes back with the Bishop
to e6 and now Rudi to attacking the
Queen Queen to c7 and this is tal says
that this is the critical not critical
moment of the game but critical moment
where White has to find a decent plan to
continue playing this game if Fischer
can bring this rook over to d8 and
exchange rooks on the D file then black
solved all of his problems so here white
has to do something to really prevent
black or or or or at least make it
harder for for Fischer so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find a
move that would you know make it really
hard for Fischer to bring the rook over
to d8 as I always say one of my favorite
trilogies aside from the fantasy once
his strategy and tactics by gurgi
Mihailovich listen and one of the books
in the trilogy is about finding a game
plan so it's a very interesting feel
free to pause the video here and find a
move the amount of plates to really make
it hard for Fischer for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent finder of plans and for
those who just want to enjoy Bishop to
g4 Bishop to g4 a very nice idea because
the bishop on e6 is undefended and also
attacked you cannot move the bishop if
you move the bishop then rook to d7 is
coming if you capture the bishop and
then Queen captures you might want to
play rook a to d8 now but it doesn't
work because simply Queen to e6 check
King moves rook to d1 again doubling
rooks on the D file after rook captures
rook captures and you bring another look
over here it seems that black solved all
of his plans abut
black is completely lost here he
captures on f6
rook after sandy 2-under now simply
Queen to f7 there are no defenses a good
defenses against Queen captures and g7
checkmate and Queen to e8 which would
following checkmate so here mushroom
captures Bishop captures with Czech pawn
captures and now of course not capturing
the Queen but rather Queen to f8 and
this will be checkmate
another thing after Bishop captures and
Queen captures on g4 black could go F
captures on e5 but again Queenie sucks
check King moves and now rook comes to
d7 and it's all over
Queen b8 Queen captures on e7 black is
getting destroyed here so a lot of a lot
of good ideas here after Bishop to g4
you might also try a move like f5 simply
you know blocking everything on the King
side and only then to bring the rook
over to the 8th but again it doesn't
work bunch up to have three attacking
the rook road goes to d8 now comes
Bishop to d5 attacking the bishop on e6
Bishop captures rook captures and now
again you haven't achieved anything it's
white who controls the D file you cannot
trade here because Queen captures with
check King moves and rook comes to be
one its again a white who controls the D
file it's probably a winning advantage
for white so very hard to find a good
move here for Fischer
so here Fischer went into a sink and he
played Queen to c8 seems very reasonable
now Fischer is the one actually
threatening to capture on g4 as the
bishop is now attacked twice capturing
an e6 would only give ya would only make
it easy for black because now while you
could play rook to d7 it doesn't really
help you in a way that you can ever
increase the pressure on the D file so
the mono doesn't go for this instead he
goes Bishop to f3
after this Queen to c8 move he moves the
bishop back and the now Fischer plays
rook to b8 getting the rock out of the
way Queen e2 and now rock to d8 so
Fisher didn't manage to bring a rook
over to the D file but it will not be
all that simple rook F to d1 doubling
rooks we have rook captures and now
Queen captures immediately grabbing hold
of the D file
tal mentions that perhaps rook captures
would have been slightly better because
after Queen to c7 e captures on f6 he
captures on f6 Queen 31 he thinks that
this battery is better than the rock
Queen battery but okay
the amount of idea also works rook to D
to Queen captures and D to immediately
in grabbing the D file and the now Queen
to e8 before you manage to do something
about these pawns and bring the bishop
over here there's really no taking
control of anything for black so he
captures on f6 he captures on f6 and the
now Queen to d6
the mono is now threatening Queen to c7
and making the the default available for
the rook rook to c8 Fischer doesn't
allow Queen to c6 we have a five and the
now comes a bishop to f8 attack mean
tomorrow's Queen Queen back to D - and
now Bishop to e7
now rope to d8 is definitely a plan for
Fischer and here it seems the black
solved all of his problems
rush up to d5 another elegant attacking
idea by taimanov
Queen to f7 we have Bishop captures on
e6 Queen captures on e6 and now Queen to
d7 the amount of manages to infiltrate
here you do know you don't have time to
capture on e3 if you capture an e3 this
does come with check but Bishop to f2
attacks the Queen and there's no way to
defend the rope and c8 so after Queen
dd7
came to f7 here a very nice idea
guarding everything the Queen is
guarding the rook so Queen captures on
a7 and here again even though the Queen
is not attacking the rook you don't have
time for Queen captures on e3 because
Mitchell blocks Queen characters and now
a capture some b6 will create too
powerful of a passed pawn so after Queen
e7 Queen a 7 but B captures on a5 Bobby
eliminates the D passed pawn and here we
have e for again a beautiful attacking
move by time on of really all of the
games that have been played time onyx
playing beautiful attacking chest a
really creative chest now capturing here
would immediately lose the rook to e1
the queen has nowhere to go as Queen
captures on e7 is coming and even this
rook to e8 idea with the idea of trading
Queen so loses Queen to c7 now there's
no way to continue attacking the White
Queen this Queen has to move and then
rook or Queen captures on e7 will win
you the game
so after e4 first Fischer goes Queen to
c6 we have looked at e7 now with a nice
attack against the fishery 7 Bishop
and here we have Queen captures on e for
grabbing upon and defending the bishop
h3 making room for the king and here you
have to see that okay rook - it seems
like a nice idea threatening threatening
the Queen but it doesn't worry because
simply rook captures and then after
Queen captures then the rook is
unguarded another thing after h3
Talmadge's King to e8
also doesn't work because Queen rook
comes to d1 and a threatening Queen d7
check but also rook e1 as the bishop is
guarding the H the e1 square so after h3
we have a for Fischer starts pushing his
passport bishop to have two attacking
the pawn on c5 as the bishop on e7 is
pinned and here we have King to f8 a
very important move by Fischer if
Fischer continued with a3 pushing the
pawn then Bishop captures on c5 would
would go in a White's favor for example
rook captures Queen captures and the now
a2 we have Queen to a7 guarding a 1 but
it doesn't matter Queen e1 check King
moves to h2 now Queen to a-1 rook
captures on e7 Queen has to capture a
Queen captures and now Queen captures on
a1 I will bring you to a Queen's endgame
where time on would be up upon so after
this Bishop to have to move attacking c5
Fischer plays King to f8 he waits with
pawn to h3
we have c4 and now comes pawn to e3 a
very nice idea Fischer says that you can
capture my from my passport but I will
then get a lot of activity we have Queen
captures on a three and now rook to e8
and now there is no double threat
against the bishop on e7 so Luke 2:8 is
not possible we have Queen - B - and now
Kings the e8 attacking the rook Queen b5
threatening all sorts of discoveries
looking back to f8 and now comes rope to
d1 you don't want to allow the black
rook to come to a one route captures an
e7 tile mentions doesn't really give
black hole that much trouble here King
captures Bishop captures and c5 king f7
you don't have a passed pawn and perhaps
you could start escorting it with the
bishop and the Queen but
and the queen is simply simply too much
to handle so after King to a fate rook
to d1
and at allowing okay one Czech Queen
captures on f4 and now better captures
on c5 Bishop captures winged captures on
c5 with check King to g7 and now rook to
f1 attacking the Queen Fischer plates
Queen to e4 also possible was a queen
here but tamaño does have a past C pawn
so perhaps not go into a Roxanne the
game immediately
Fischer opts for Queen to e4 we have
Queen to c7 check Fisher place honking
to h6 and it seems that Fisher's f6 pawn
is now undefended but here probably
Queen to see rope to a for attacking
Fisher's Queen and then you have to
allow a couple of checks or simply Queen
to b6 keeping everything on the board
works pretty well you know you start
escorting the pawn here and I mean White
will not be able to win this game but
pretty much it's only white that can win
this game due to the free pass pawn but
here after this King to h6 move much
like what happened to Cara wanna in his
game against Dominguez yesterday in the
st. Louis revenant blitz event here at a
man of thought that this was actually a
free pawn
he played rook captures on f6 and
unfortunately for Mark Damon event
although of the Soviet Union pause the
video here and find the idea of time on
of missed here it's not very complicated
and it's really unimaginable that's time
out of play the move like this but yeah
pause the video here and you know we win
this game for Fischer so he can have his
500 lead in this match so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show here the idea is Queen to
d4 seems pretty reasonable the king is
in check the rook is also attacked so if
you move the King you're gonna lose the
rook if you block with the rook which
was played in the game Fischer played
rook to e1 check and now there are no
more moves you have to play King to h2
and then after you play Queen captures
an f2 there are no checks for the White
Queen so no tricks tomorrow would simply
be a rope down so after this rook to a-1
move check the amount of resigned to the
game so unimaginable I mean it's such a
such a weird match first first okay
winning in Game one tomorrow was better
he had the attack Fischer won then comes
game to game to his adjourned and game
tree a three started official wins Game
three after that beautiful beautiful
defending sequence worth amount of mrs.
Queen to h3 and then tomorrow has to
continue playing game to which was a
completely drawn in game but he loses it
because he was either too tired or he
didn't have time to analyze it because
he was preparing for the Game three that
he lost after so many hours then came
Game four you've seen Game four or if
you haven't there is a link to it in the
description below where he Fischer
played the absolute masterpiece of
endgame technique and now he plays Game
five where he plays this unimaginable
rook captures on f6 move
I mean Fischer is not one to blunder
pawns he's been known to blunder a piece
like perhaps in game one versus passkey
but you know very rarely a pawn but yeah
the amount of plated Queen d4 check
roadblocks rook a1 and Fischer is now
five points in the lead in this match
and as the 1971 candidates matches were
you know thought of there will be it
will be a ten game match so as Fischer
is already five points in the lead now
the man of breakeven has to win five
games in a row
so if Fisher gets even one draw now it's
basically just over
so although the game the match is pretty
much over time enough can still you know
it's it will be a matter of Honor you
know the Soviet Union doesn't want to
print out in the newspapers the other
day that the amount of lost for example
six to zero so whatever a points the
amount of can muster up until the end of
the match will definitely go in in his
and in Soviets favor
so that's game number five of the 1971
can do this match between mark Semenov
and Bobby Fischer I do hope you enjoyed
it and that you're enjoying the coverage
of the candidates of the Palma de
Majorca intra zonal of the entire Bobby
Fischer story I would like to thank
Stephen green moonshee Aubry clea and
the Damocles ferrets for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon perhaps
with a couple of videos from from st.
Louis but also continuing the Bobby
Fischer series and the quick
announcement
I bought user of a nice microphone for
his birthday the one I'm using so he
made a video a video in as a thank you
video he analyzed one of my bullet games
which is funny because you know you
shouldn't will analyze bullet games
unless Carlson played it but you know
still if you want to check it out
I do invite you to check it out as now
the audio on his channel has improved
immensely so a link to that will also be
in the description below thank you all
and I'll see you soon